i'm jay horton i make movies that make
money this is how
jay why do you say you are a filmmaker
who makes money
um
well i'm making a very like specific
style of movie i'm making low budget
features you know usually under a
hundred thousand dollars and the vast
majority of filmmakers that i talk to
that are making movies at this level a
lot of them aren't making money you know
they're losing from the distributors or
you know they're self-distributing and
not doing anything um they don't know
how to make money i
myself you know i've directed 25 feature
films at this point and you know the
first probably 10 years of my career
like i wasn't making a lot of money on
these movies like i i didn't know how i
didn't know how to navigate it
um i kind of learned how
later on
and
you know i like to make it so that other
filmmakers can maybe get to that point
sooner than i did and so i like to share
some of that knowledge with them you
know it took it took me a long time
before my you know my movies were
breaking even or making money and so
and and on top of that as i was starting
my youtube channel you know i was uh you
know there's a couple of growth experts
that i'm following and they have their
little catchphrases i was like i need
some kind of catchphrase and it just
like that just came out i was getting
ready to do it and i was like i'm jay
horton i make movies that make money
this is how you know and it just it just
felt like something that would interest
other filmmakers which was you know the
whole goal of the channel in the first
place right you do that in your intro to
the videos yeah it does work when did
you become the filmmaker who makes money
um
so i've made money with my films
from the beginning you know i did i did
struggle at the beginning
but you know pretty much i mean my first
movie was distributed in 2003 uh by york
entertainment now it didn't make
anything but
from that and it getting distributed and
out there um i started landing other
filmmaking jobs and that's where i first
started to make money but like when i
say you know i'm jay horn i'm a i make
movies that make money i mean i produce
movies i direct movies and i make money
off those movies like i'm not
necessarily talking about you know hey i
got i get hired as a editor or a dp
which i have done
but you know i'm specifically talking
about making money off the ex exhibition
of the movies and i would say
that started
probably like on a study about
five years ago about five years when
like right around the time that amazon
started opening up for streaming
you know and that's where i first
started getting the rights back from
some of my older films and finding that
you actually could make a little bit of
money on your own and over the years
i've just gotten better and better at
marketing them at picking the movies and
you know making more money with them
do you think that was a big contributor
is
going back and getting those rights back
or
new movies going forward once amazon
prime opened up yeah there's a little
bit of both i mean it was the the old
movies uh coming back up for license
that made me realize that i could be a
like an entrepreneurial producer you
know i had um
rise of the undead and edges of darkness
they were released in 2003 and 2008. um
around
2014 or 15 i got the rights back for
both of those within like a year
and i honestly at the time i didn't know
what to do with them
and
there was a
a
service called createspace um it's owned
by amazon but it was basically created
for self publishers like authors um but
they were doing a thing where you could
give them like your iso video file from
your movie for dvd and they would make
videos on demand or dvds on demand and
real soon after that they started giving
you the option to go on to amazon prime
and so this was before prime video
direct but it's still basically
a similar process like you'd upload
yourself and get it up
so i put these two movies up on amazon
prime and
they were making a few bucks a month
like like nothing big
and then out of nowhere uh one of them
popped up to like a thousand a month
and then it kind of hit me i was like oh
my gosh like what if this was a new
movie you know because this is like a 10
year old title at this point
and it's it's doing all right um so then
i started seriously considering you know
producing movies and like hey here's
somewhere where i could put them even if
i didn't do traditional distribution
and so i you know it was always in the
back of my mind and then after
i had a little
sidetrack with gas money pictures where
i was doing animation animation studio
and that took me off movies for about
two years but then when i came back
um i was like hey i'm going to do this
like self-produce you know
self-distribute thing and i started
making documentaries and that's that's
where i really
got immersed in like the streaming and
amazon and then later film hub and then
back into traditional distribution
was that the point of no return when you
saw that
email or whatever with a thousand
dollars yes yes because like from from
that point on i realized that hey i can
self-generate material i can make these
movies on my own without answering to
anyone
and i can make a
you know a reasonable amount of money on
it you know if i made a thousand on this
older one could i make five thousand or
ten thousand with a newer one so i was
like hey i didn't i don't i don't need
anybody to do this there's no
gatekeeping it's like it's almost anyone
could put a movie up there
so yeah it really really opened up the
the doors to me being my own
boss
and with this thousand dollars in one
month were there rumblings online did
you see more
was this a complete surprise complete
surprise so i was doing absolutely no
promotion for it like you know no no
social media had no social media
presence you know the like i said the
movie was 10 years old i had pretty much
written them off at that point
it was totally just a fluke of the
algorithm you know it was on amazon and
a certain group of people started
watching it and it just
it just took off
you know it got a bunch of reviews after
that and still not a ton like you'll
hear people talking about how critical
user reviews on amazon are but i've
never really found that to be true
i don't think it hurts but i have plenty
of movies that have made you know 5 000
a month 10 000 a month and they have you
know less than 200 reviews so i never
thought that was a big thing but yeah it
just it really opened up from that point
on i was just like hey this is what i
want to do and i've always had kind of a
problem working for people i just i you
know i always wanted to be my own boss
so here here it was i can do it
did you quit a job after that or you
were freelance so i was freelancing
around this time i was freelancing a lot
so i was primarily making my living as
an editor
i worked for fox cutting promos for a
while i would cut other people's
features
i was hired to direct other people's
features like i directed about 10
feature films for a company called amg
film partners and you know they were all
between 25 and 50 000
um after i saw the self distribution
thing and it took a few years now you
know because i started making the docs
and you know i'd do one here one there
took about a year before like my money
was steady enough to where i say hey i
don't have to do freelance anymore and i
did so i haven't done a freelance job in
probably three years now
well i directed one documentary last
year that was a for hire but it was
based off my you know the stuff i'm
doing now